on youtube do you see happy couples mr b
surprised his girlfriend with a hundred
thousand roses
hundred thousand roses that's not good
how did you see the world when you were
a kid
[Music]
we brought in three couples to receive
counselling from kid therapists
to see if a kid's perspective could
guide the couples through their
relationship struggles
do you know what therapist is i think a
therapist is someone who helps
other people people or couples if
they're having a bad day or
are in a bad or in or if they are in a
bad situation
hi my name is isabelle hello hi
this is ruby i'm andrew nice to meet you
nice to meet you too
hello my name is evan hi evan thank you
hello
are you gavin yes so how are you guys
feeling today
you're feeling good well i'm feeling
nervous i've never done it same here
we have a couple things that we might
need to work on
so um i'm very very different
from my wife here kathy i love video
games a lot
same here but that means i also like to
stay at home a lot and just kind of do
things
you know on my own and play video games
with my friends
yeah so i prefer going out so i like
hanging out with my friends outside i
like going out hiking
picnic you know the park yeah i actually
have a park
by me i also like to ride bikes and
stuff yeah so our problem is that i like
going out and he prefers staying indoor
so every weekend we have
you know trouble deciding what to do and
we always argue about it
wait i have an idea um you know pokemon
go
it's like a video game but you can walk
around you can try that out
so the first of the week you play video
games that he likes
and then the other 50 of the week then
you'll have to
do what she likes okay 50 50.
i like that a lot right now it's 80
video games and 20
going out so we have to split it halfway
down yeah i like that that's fair
yeah yeah okay so what do you guys
disagree on
do we disagree on do you have
instagram no well we disagree on
instagram sometimes
i don't know i sometimes have a problem
that you don't like to post me on your
instagram
you should be proud of who you're with
like you should want to post them
i don't know just sometimes it feels
like he tries to hide me
i don't think that it's much of a big
deal if you want to contact virtually
you should
use sex messages face time or
resume yeah you can zoom me
yeah we could i guess huh how can i help
you guys
huh i get a little grumpy when i have a
bad day yeah
i come home and i do put it on her
sometimes and
i don't know how to deal with this
sometimes i don't know how to make him
not be grumpy
do you know how we can fix that
well um i
i would think probably like if you guys
have like other rooms
you could go to one room and then you
can go to one room
okay and then when you cool down you can
tell her
all about it yeah that's a good idea i
don't know why i think of that
we never thought of that so good
suggestion
i feel like we sort of disagree on
things when it comes to like jealousy
and like fear of losing someone like all
relationships end
and it is going to either end in breakup
and death or divorce
are you afraid that i will lose i will
leave you no
okay just wondering
so if if you guys had to choose would
you propose right now
propose right now
[Music]
just straight up pull out a ring and
propose right there
that that's like you have to plan that
so i would
i would say no no like if you had it
planned
though oh if i had a plan of course yes
but like as of right now just get down
on my knees that wouldn't make sense
well i think of it like a rank
like karate you have like this belt
you're at the second highest ranking and
then when you get married you go
to a black belt okay
so you think you'd be like a level up
yes okay
i do have something else someone else's
advice with though okay
so at home we live together and
i do everything around the house and
he's great at cooking so he does the
cooking
but i do everything else do you think
that's fair amount of chores
how can we make that more fair um you do
50 of the house and he does yeah and
then he does the other 50
yeah but cooking is a lot of work you
have to chop the stuff
you have to buy the stuff i cook every
single day but you only clean every
three or four days
i clean the kitchen every day that's
true yeah
you have a point i have an idea a first
teacher how to cook
okay that's true that's good first
started eggs
even i can make scrambled eggs you just
i'm turning the oven on
get a pan wrap the eggs scramble them up
done thank you for teaching so he should
teach me how to cook i should
help him cook more and he should help me
clean more yes
i love that her and my sister don't
really get along
yeah and i'm not sure why you know i
don't know how to talk to her
she doesn't talk to me so how do you
think
i should try to befriend her probably
get her like a gift and tell her how you
really feel like
oh i think you're not like being nice
and
probably say something like that okay
well do you think she would want to talk
to me though
probably give her flowers and a card or
like a teddy bear like most people do
kind of oh okay
she loves nightmare before christmas oh
you see yeah you should have told me
that well there you go
okay on youtube do you see happy couples
oh yeah mr b surprised his girlfriend
with a hundred thousand roses
hundred thousand roses that's not good
like if she wants
like a necklace or ring you should
save up to buy what she wants okay
i think he does do that he surprises me
a lot so
i think that was good advice he's
meeting those requirements right now
well i appreciate you taking the time
out to sit down and talk our problems
with us
thanks kevin thank you we're gonna find
those games okay bye
bye nice to meet you nice meeting you
too thanks doc
all right
[Music]
what do you think makes a relationship
work that they
trust in each other and to love each
other
and not cheat on each other i think love
is a level beyond friendship
it takes a lot of help
and a lot of responsibility and trust to
make our
relationship work my best suggestion for
games
among us are friday night among us is
like
oh there's imposters and stuff and then
friday night funkin is like it's like a
beat game
roblox is pretty good because it has a
whole bunch of different games
there's a game called sims i don't
really like it but my mom does because
like it's like
a real life but instead of a game do you
think she'll like that
maybe i should try it out yes